[Music]
now the going brush my name it spirit
bad I'll shake you cat how you do it
I a cellphone for me after Happy New
Year
alright what else is it we gotta pick up
this stupid nose mother they read this
oh I should have known should've [ __ ]
known ah ok what I do okay we go back to
mock or whatever the [ __ ] is but fires
we have to record a message
I think I already did this but let's do
it again for just one that's missing oh
yes this is yes it's your mom mrs.
Forrest no it's got fired from my job
and so right now yeah yeah give me my
money
all right hey said King Kelly sleeping
all right
so let's call and go to what is your
name I don't remember
I was [ __ ] it all right let me get out
of my face you [ __ ] actor ah all
right let's call geek cellphone let's
just call him that nine nine seven nine
nine well now I don't have to memorize
anymore this is our from why couldn't
this have this before
alright let's just teleport and [ __ ] it
we're not literally [ __ ] it just [ __ ] it
finished huh
baraz stop harassing me
ah Caramba I actually had to change my
phone number because so many of you bros
kept calling me and you keep calling my
dad by the way so if you ever look up my
number don't call it cuz it's my dad and
he's getting pissed off sir alright we
got a cell phone and was I supposed to
do
armed soldier right that's the best you
can come up with it stupid okay let's
write it em hey come on you can do it
okay you [ __ ] okay ah stay stay ah yes
wish Oh gasps give me that [ __ ] No ah
this is so [ __ ] all right good
evening uh hi there now I I'm had extra
light to read it good evening and animus
ah Wow packed houses no I didn't think I
read it all the time down no okay I'm
this guy I'm sorry y'all okay alright we
have a new phone number a new message is
that from him as well
alright let's just keep calling people
look at fish all right where's the
number how do I go all right it got to
be this one let's save Fame station
[Music]
station same station now all right let's
see where this is biggie apart so
freakin fun
oh you pump you pretty I'm a party right
now you want to gonna come over and you
relax and maybe later we can just ah
just leg up on that stupid pervert I
don't even know anymore
oh she stole no she the end oh oh it's
on she's called my notepad oh oh she's
gonna pay q-bag for that so the door was
open I what the hell oh no one she's my
notepad no oh no oh this is one of the
girls toilet I never understand how the
[ __ ] they work I think you just shove
your butt in there and just click a
button it starts sucking this is that's
just what I think
all right anyone in here Oh what the
hell
how did she even hang in the lamp don't
hang at a lamp brah that's what my hours
are saying then I kept doing it inch
didn't end well didn't have cat Oh shall
fall let's see what that is huh ah
[ __ ] gay
colors in the background the best one
was your puppy push it so much it's so
fresh so digital hit so we can give me a
hard time nearly all right no that's not
how you open it alright so this is the
art room I don't know if you remember
this one we met the other girl the other
time Kristen is wet
oh we were in the ladies bathroom I know
I'm a pervert yeah yeah I like that
mmm all right so we need to find art
room that's a classroom and that's
another classroom and by the look of it
I should not a classroom well I gotta
technically Oh will I should go
downstairs hello anyone here I realize
you can actually turn off your
flashlight how the hell I do it let's
say so I don't do anything stupid
oh that's how you crouch that's how you
open your phone
as I open the map this well I saw
something
laughs packet let's just go down there
looking for it all right
let's find this this could be a computer
room nope it is not there computer room
I remember specifically it's our room
because there were those titties there
oh don't turn around you scare the
living penis out of me nothing my penis
is live I guess technically it's alive I
[ __ ] just changed objectives all
right just keep looking for that room as
a pouch my dog keep barking in the
background please shut up dog trying to
record stuff here
very unprofessional dog disappointed
that oh oh oh oh are you fanny and it's
a he's back oh there he goes
uh-uh oh no I understand him if the fat
is following I hate the fatty but now I
hate the guy the guy leaving Maude I
suppose it doesn't matter of time though
I hope they can get away I can do
anything just because I am I am too busy
with my nipples okay um so they came
from here does that mean I have to go
there or should I save them oh this well
actually I'm gonna save stay she's a -
Carlo what are you say it uh what do we
got here yeah what it is this is a
cooking preparation room got - oh stop
turning around scared of living [ __ ]
what I keep saying that it's very
offensive to other parks I don't know
why everything someone will write in the
comment I'm a [ __ ] and I'm offended okay
audio-visual is no I don't think this is
it
oh it's what instruments are allowed
every inch remains I think we have to go
down so let's go down
down down down I'm swimming around in a
corner I'm swimming around in a corridor
I'm swimming around in a cone you know I
try to not [ __ ] my pants let's go down
the stairs let's try not to kill herself
we gotta find that mystery of the school
hospital and all this [ __ ]
oh no it's patty oh [ __ ] me all right
the only one way to deal with Patty's
who want your Swedish meatballs
stop instead enough dealing with this
[ __ ] fat-ass here over here hey you
hey fat ass come here I know you're busy
eating oh maybe that's not a good idea
to interrupt someone who's eating
especially when they're fat hello I need
to go there get out of my face huh stop
I mustn't try to get your phone I don't
know don't push me oh that's [ __ ] Oh
yeah
I she is that I knew it all right let's
go where the sound is coming from she
obviously is not a bro all right we've
got he yes yeah I found it
sorry that's two over exaggerated over
what are you doing what what are you
doing
watch F [ __ ] did I [ __ ] up my keyboard
hi [ __ ] I'm here I was titties don't
worry all right
can sing me it's gonna be flag who
closed the door all right titties tell
me what you do titties daddy's talk to
me what do I do - don't ignore me you
never trust a tease always trying to
lower you in all right this is where it
was I remember these do you remember
this bras this is where the text message
was I'm clearly here it's like what the
[ __ ] do you want from me why I'm not
doing this [ __ ] all right you want to
all you want to [ __ ] with me is I get it
you want to know show [ __ ] don't you
all right there's obviously something
there but I want to say it's to save
station hey did I do it oh yeah it's
right there all right can I lose this
[ __ ] the statue just is the it's a
statue
yeah okay I'm not clicking stop [ __ ]
I'm not clicking holy [ __ ]
statue man wearing a toga it's a statue
of a war wearing a helmet
very interesting please tell me more I
really like this oh oh this is it this
is what I need to pick up all right
then up reading to pass everybody know
then the - the three teenage girls at
Saudi high school month ago it's very
quiet it was quite a story when the
three sorry
this dude came from from this and and
this had problem she died a few hours
later the first one discovered them
and a junior would stop by the lateral
on top it's it's not dyslexia it's
lawless
yeah yes I just invented a to check him
to go oh oh oh now see girls gonna show
up yeah I knew it
I'm a genius and now I'm gonna be all
like hey my net bothers you like mine
ever - you liked him I thought that you
were a ghost glad to see that you're
alive
alright we're gonna end it here brush
hope you enjoyed this episode
I can favorite if you did subscribe to
come abroad today and I'll see your net
the next time where do that would be
some sex she will healing look at that
face she obviously needs it
alright I'm gonna hear
[Music]
Bondi tender business yeah